hi everyone
this is professor mdos science and today
i want to compare the schrodinger and
high simple pictures of time evolution
in another one of our videos on rigorous
quantum mechanics in our study of
quantum mechanics so far we've discussed
time evolution by means of the
schrollinger equation the joiner
equation describes how quantum states
evolve in time as determined by the
hamiltonian of the system this approach
to time evolution is called the
schrodinger picture today we'll learn
there are many ways in which we can
describe time evolution in quantum
mechanics they're all conceptually
different but mathematically equivalent
specifically today we'll introduce the
heisenberg picture of time evolution in
which quantum states do not evolve in
time instead in the heisenberg picture
it is observables that encode the time
evolution of the system let's go
let's start with a quick recap of time
evolution in quantum mechanics as we
know it so far we learned today that
this particular way of doing time
evolution has a name it is called the
drawinger picture
at this point it won't yet be clear why
we call it a picture but it will become
clear during the video
let's start with states at an initial
time t0 we write the quantum state psi
of the system using a ket like this
in today's video we'll add a capital s
sub index to all states here to make it
clear when we're discussing the
schrodinger picture
in the schrolinger picture quantum
states evolve in time
this is what we've always done so far so
good
and what this means is that at a later
time t
the quantum state is now given by this
new cut
the key question now is how do we go
from the state at this initial time
to the state at this later time
the answer to this question is given by
postulate 6 of quantum mechanics the
time evolution is governed by the
schrodinger equation
if you need a refresher about the
schrodinger equation you can find the
relevant video linked in the description
but mathematically what we have is that
i h bar times the rate of change of the
state
is equal to the hamiltonian acting on
the state
and remember that the hamiltonian is the
hermitian operator associated with the
total energy of the system
i'm again using the sub-index s for
states here and here and for observables
like the hamiltonian here
in all cases to highlight that we're
working in the schrodinger picture
sticking with the schroedinger picture
let's now turn to observables
in our videos on quantum mechanics we've
been mostly concerned with time
independent observables like position
momentum angular momentum or kinetic
energy
each of these is represented by a
hermitian operator and these operators
are time independent
for example we write the momentum
operator in 1d
as p-hat
again i'm including a capital s
sub-index to make it clear that this
operator corresponds to an observable
written in the schrodinger picture
in the position representation
the momentum operator becomes minus i h
bar times the derivative with respect to
x
as another example the kinetic energy
operator in 1d is p squared over 2m
and in the position representation
it becomes minus h bar squared over 2m
multiplying the second derivative with
respect to x
the same is true for other operators we
typically use such as the position or
angle momentum operators which are all
time independent
at this point it is very important to
clarify that we can also have time
dependent observables in the joiner
picture
for example we could have a particle
moving in a 1d potential whose magnitude
oscillates in time say following a
sinusoidal dependence
in this example we write its hamiltonian
operator hs
as equal to the kinetic energy which is
time independent
plus a generic potential
with the associated sinusoidal time
dependence
now you may wonder what an example of a
time dependent potential may be and a
good example is that arising from
electromagnetic radiation
so overall in this rollinger picture we
have many operators such as the ones up
here that are time independent and we
can also have operators with an explicit
time dependence such as the hamiltonian
down here
in elementary quantum mechanics we
typically consider time independent
hamiltonians but the most general case
is one in which the hamiltonian is time
dependent and to keep the discussion
general you may have noticed that i used
the time dependent hamiltonian in the
jointer equation of the previous slide
another key insight we need for today's
video is that we can rephrase the time
evolution of quantum states in terms of
the so-called time evolution operator
if you need a refresher about the time
evolution operator i encourage you to
check out the corresponding video that
is linked in the description
but as a brief summary as the
schrolinger equation is a linear
equation we can write the state psi of t
as equal to a linear operator u of t t0
acting on the state at the initial time
which is psi of t0
the operator u here is the time
evolution operator
and it depends on the initial time t0
and the final time t
now you may note that i'm not using an s
up index for u here and this is because
i'm reserving s of indices for states
and observables and u is not an
observable it's in fact a unitary
operator
putting everything together we can use
the schroedinger equation as in the
previous slide or the time evolution
operator as in this slide and they are
both equivalent ways of going from the
initial state to the final state of the
system when working in the schroedinger
picture of quantum mechanics
in both cases time evolution is governed
by the hamiltonian
in particular we find in the video on
the time evolution operator that this
operator obeys this differential
equation involving the hamiltonian
and also that it is subject to this
initial condition at equal times for its
argument
if the hamiltonian is time independent
we find in the video on the time
evolution operator that it's actually
relatively easy to solve this equation
up here and we can then write the
explicit form for u
as equal to this exponential function of
the hamiltonian
however if the hamiltonian depends
explicitly on time
then the form that the time evolution
operator takes is more complex and for
example it may require writing it in the
form of a dyson series
so
is what we've been discussing the only
way in which we can describe time
evolution in quantum mechanics
well it turns out it's not
there are many alternative ways to
interpret the physics behind time
evolution
even though they're all mathematically
equivalent and result in the same
predictions they represent conceptually
different time evolution mechanisms
each of these alternatives is called a
picture
with a drawlinger picture being simply
one possibility
to see how this comes about let's start
with a simple example to gain some
intuition
let's consider a quantum state psi at
time t
which remember is related to the state
at time t0 via this equation
let's also consider an observable
described by an operator a
and for simplicity let's take it to be
time independent
i'm again using the capital s sub
indices to indicate after now these are
in the schrodinger picture
we can next construct the expectation
value of observable a in state psi at
time t in the usual way
to make progress we're now going to use
this relation up here to rewrite the
expectation value in terms of the state
at time t 0.
we start with the brass i t 0
and then we have the add joint of the
time evolution operator
we then have a
we then get the time evolution operator
and finally the cat's psi at t0
in the drawinger picture the bra at time
t 0 and the add joint of the time
evolution operator go together
to get the bra at a different time t
similarly the time evolution operator
and the ket go together to get the state
at time t
trivially the operator is what it is
however
if we look at this expression from a
purely mathematical point of view we can
see that we could instead group the time
evolution operators together with a like
this
and define a new operator a at time t
which for reasons that will become
obvious in a moment with label with a
capital h sub index
in this alternative regrouping we get
the bra at time t 0
and the ket at time t 0.
as a result we could rewrite the
expectation value as the bra side t0
then a time dependent operator a
and then the ket side t0
so what does all of this mean
in the original form here we have that
the states are time dependent here and
here
while the operator is time independent
here
as we've discussed this is the way in
which we've been doing things so far and
is what we call the schrollinger picture
of time evolution
but we now see that in the new form of
the expectation value here
the quantum states here
and here are evaluated at a fixed time
d0 and therefore time independent
by contrast the operator here
is time dependent
this provides an alternative but
equivalent formulation of time evolution
in quantum mechanics
and this particular alternative is what
we call the heisenberg picture
in the heisenberg picture
quantum states psi
are equal to the corresponding states in
the schroedinger picture at a fixed time
t0
this means that quantum state in the
heisenberg picture are time independent
and this is actually the defining
feature of this picture
also note that i've included the
subindex capital h here to indicate that
we're working in the heisenberg picture
in the heisenberg picture the time
dependence is now captured by the
observables
which are related to those in the
jollinger picture by this equation
and now we see the reason why we include
the h sub index here
from this discussion the heisenberg
picture appears to be a mathematical
trick to rewrite the expectation value
what we'll do in the rest of the video
is to provide a proper justification of
this mathematical trick and for that we
first need to consider unitary operators
and unitary transformations
so
to put the preceding discussion on firm
ground we need to make use of an
important property of the time evolution
operator it's a unitary operator
for this reason we need a quick
refresher about unitary operators and
we'll generally denote them with a
capital u
and again for the full details i refer
you to the video linked in the
description
a unitary operator is an operator whose
inverse
is equal to its adjoint
we can equivalently rewrite this
condition as u dagger u equal to u u
dagger
which in turn is equal to the identity
for our purposes today we also need to
consider what are called unitary
transformations
consider state psi we can define a new
state
psi prime
by applying a unitary operator u on psi
this action of u on psi is called the
unitary transformation and the key point
about unitary transformations is that
they conserve the scalar product of
states
what this means is that if we pick a
second state phi
and also construct the same unitary
transformation
then the scalar product of the
transformed states
is equal to the scalar product of the
original states
as a corollary of this result if the two
states are the same we can conclude that
unitary transformations conserve the
norm
let's now consider observables
we start with an operator a
and then we can define a new operator
a prime
which is the unitary transformation of a
and is given by u
a
u dagger
we again find that the bracket phi prime
a prime c prime of the unitary
transforms
is equal to the original bracket phi a
psi
overall unitary transformations are the
extension of orthogonal transformations
from real to complex vector spaces and
they find many applications in quantum
mechanics including the time evolution
operator we're interested in today
and this is it for the refresher on
unitary operators and unitary
transformations we're now ready to
explore the different pictures in which
we can describe time evolution in
quantum mechanics
let's first consider why we can have
different pictures of time evolution in
quantum mechanics
the key insight is that all of the
predictions of quantum mechanics
for example the probability of obtaining
a particular measurement outcome or the
expectation value of a particular
observable
are all given by scalar products
to give an example imagine we have a
quantum system in state psi
and we again use the subindex s notation
to indicate that we're working in this
ringer picture
suppose also that we consider an
observable a
whose associated operator obeys this
eigenvalue equation
now the notation for the eigenstate is
somewhat involved but essentially the
sub index n here indicates the different
eigenstates and the sub index s here in
the case that we work in the showing our
picture
in this setup the probability of
obtaining lambda n when we measure a in
state psi
is given by this expression which
involves the bracket between u n
and psi
the expectation value of a in state psi
is given by this other expression which
involves the bracket psi a psi
why is this important
as we've just discussed in the previous
slide a unitary transformation is a
transformation that we can apply to
states here
and operators here
that crucially does not change the
scalar product
this means that we can apply any unitary
transformation to our states and
observables and the predictions of
quantum mechanics which are all given by
scalar products will remain unchanged
and what does this have to do with time
evolution
well the time evolution operator is a
unitary operator
this means that we can use the time
evolution operator to apply a unitary
transformation on the states and
observables of the drawinger picture
and doing so will obtain an alternative
but equally valid description of time
evolution in quantum mechanics
and each of these alternative
descriptions is called a picture
now there are infinitely many unitary
transformations we can apply to the
states and observables in the showing
our picture so in principle there are
infinitely many pictures of quantum
mechanics
however as you can probably imagine only
some of these alternative pictures are
practically useful
as we've seen earlier the heisenberg
picture arises from one of these
possible unitary transformations
specifically the one which makes states
time independent
there is a third useful picture of
quantum mechanics called the interaction
picture which involves a different
transformation of states and observables
the interaction picture is particularly
useful to study quantum systems with
time dependent potentials and you can
find more details about the interaction
picture in the videos linked in the
description
we're now finally ready to define the
heisenberg picture more formally
the heisenberg picture is defined as the
one for which quantum states are time
independent
now given this definition what the
states look like in the heisenberg
picture
to answer this question we need to find
the appropriate unitary transformation
that we can apply to the state in the
joinery picture so that we end up with
time independent states
to find out what this transformation is
remember that quantum states evolve in
time in the jointer picture and that the
state psi at time t
is equal to the time evolution operator
u t t 0
acting on the state psi at the initial
time t 0.
from this equation it is clear that if
we apply the inverse of u on this state
we'll get this long expression
then we can combine these two terms to
get the identity
so that we end up with the state psi at
the initial time t0
this state here is at a fixed time t0 so
it is time independent and this is
exactly what we wanted to build the
heisenberg picture
but before we give the full definition
an extra ingredient remember that the
time evolution operator is unitary which
means that we can write the inverse as
equal to the adjoint
this means that in these expressions at
the top we can use the adjoint operator
rather than the inverse operator in all
instances here or here
with this we can build the time
independent state psi in the heisenberg
picture
by applying the adjoint of the time
evolution operator
on the state psi in the joiner picture
at time t
we also know from the result up here
that it is equal to the state psi in the
joiner picture at time t 0.
note that i'm again using the sub-index
capital h here to indicate that this
state is now written in the heisenberg
picture
overall in the heisenberg picture
quantum states are time independent and
are given by this specific unitary
transformation applied to the
corresponding states in the joiner
picture
conceptually what we're doing is to pick
a reference time which we've called t0
and look at what the state of the system
in the joiner picture looks like at that
time
we then fix the state at that time t0 to
obtain the heisenberg picture
and of course we've recovered the result
we had in the earlier discussion about
the heisenberg picture
let's make some room
while the heisenberg picture is defined
as that for which states are time
independent to complete the picture we
need to explore how observables behave
given that the unitary transformation
that takes us from states in the
drawinger picture to state in the
heisenberg picture is u dagger
then we have to apply the same unitary
transformation to observables in the
schrodinger picture to obtain a general
observable a in the heisenberg picture
again i'm using the sub-index capital h
here to clarify that we're working in
the heisenberg picture
remember that for operators a unitary
transformation given by an operator u
takes this form
in our case the role of u is played by
the adjoint of the time evolution
operator
so going back to the operator in the
heisenberg picture we get the adjoint of
the time evolution operator
the observable a in the joiner picture
and then the adjoint of the adjoint of
the time evolution operator which is
simply the time evolution operator
itself
and this relation completes the
heisenberg picture by telling us how to
transform observables
again note that this result agrees with
the one we obtained earlier when we
introduced the heisenberg picture with a
simple
example now in these expressions i've
explicitly included the time dependence
of operators for both the heisenberg
picture here and the joiner picture here
this takes us to another important
aspect of the heisenberg picture
operators are in general time dependent
in the heisenberg picture
even if we have a time independent
operator in the joiner picture because
of the time variables appearing in the
time evolution operator here
and here then the corresponding
operators in the heisenberg picture will
in general be time dependent
and this is actually a situation that we
encounter very frequently as we've
discussed at the beginning of the video
many important operators like position
momentum or angular momentum are time
independent in the drawing or picture in
general these operators will be time
dependent in the heisenberg picture
now that we've defined the heisenberg
picture through the relevant unitary
transformation of states here
and of observables here
it would be good to confirm that quantum
mechanics predictions are indeed not
affected by these changes
to illustrate this we'll revisit the
simple example we already discussed
earlier we'll calculate the expectation
value of an observable a in state psi
let's start by writing this expectation
value in the schrollinger picture using
the relevant s-sub-indices
given that the time evolution operator
is a unitary operator
we have that the product of the operator
with its adjoint
is equal to the identity operator
this implies that if we insert an
identity operator at this position
and another one at this other position
then we can expand these identities in
terms of products of time evolution
operators and their adjoints and get the
state psi
then the identity operator in terms of
the product of time evolution operators
then the operator a
then the identity again expanded in
terms of time evolution operators and
finally the state psi again
we now identify this here as the bra of
the state psi in the heisenberg picture
this here has the operator in the
heisenberg picture
and this here as the ket of the state
psi in the heisenberg picture
this means that we get the expectation
value in the heisenberg picture
as expected from the general properties
of unitary transformations we have that
the expectation value in the drawinger
picture up here is equal to the
expectation value in the heisenberg
picture down here
highlighting that we can use either when
doing quantum mechanics as long as we're
consistent
also note that while the state in the
joiner picture in general depends on
time here and here
state in the heisenberg picture do not
depend on time here and here and all the
time dependence is captured by the
operator here
let's now turn to the dynamics of the
system
first remember that in the joiner
picture time evolution is captured by
quantum states and given by the joiner
equation
in the heisenberg picture quantum states
are time independent so to study time
evolution we need to look at observables
therefore to understand the dynamics in
the heisenberg picture let's consider
the time derivative of a general
observable a
using the relation between observables
in the heisenberg and showing our
pictures
we can insert this expression inside
this term
and rewrite the time derivative like
this
we can now apply the chain rule and we
get a term involving the derivative of
the u dagger
a term involving the derivative of the
observable
and the term involving the derivative of
u
now feel free to pause here to cross
check this step but it is a simple
application of the chain rule of
differentiation
remember from our discussion of the time
evolution operator that its time
derivative here
is equal to this expression
similarly we can write the time
derivative of the adjoint of the time
evolution operator
using the add joint of the same
expression like this
putting these together we can collect
the first and third terms to end up with
this prefactor multiplying this term in
which a appears before the hamiltonian
and this term in which the hamiltonian
appears before a
and we also have the term with the time
derivative of a which stays the same
let's make some room
and let's copy the latest expression we
got for the time derivative of
observable a in the heisenberg picture
to make progress we are now going to
insert the identity operator here
written as the product of u
and u dagger which you can do because u
is unitary we're also going to insert it
here
and spelling out the resulting
expression we end up with this
pre-factor
then this very long first term
minus this very long second term
and finally the time derivative of the
observable stays the same
again feel free to pause here to cross
check this long step but all we've
literally done is to insert the
identities between a and the
hamiltonian moving on we can use the
relation between the schroedinger and
heisenberg pictures to see that this
term
is simply the observable a in the
heisenberg picture
this term is simply the hamiltonian in
the heisenberg
picture this term is again the
hamiltonian in the heisenberg picture
this term
is again a in the heisenberg picture
and finally this last term is the time
derivative of a in the heisenberg
picture
putting everything together we end up
with a common factor of one over i h bar
multiplying a h
minus h a in the heisenberg picture
plus the time derivative of a in the
heisenberg picture
and let's make some room one more time
the last expression we got for the time
derivative of an operator in the
heisenberg picture
is given by this combination of the
observable and the hamiltonian
plus the time derivative term
finally note that this term in brackets
here
is simply the commutator of a and h
and overall we can arrange the equation
to this form that is used more often
so what does this all mean
in the joiner picture time evolution is
given by states and determined by the
schroinger equation and observables may
be time independent or time dependent
by contrast in the heisenberg picture
states are time independent and instead
time evolution is captured by the
observables
in this context this equation we've just
derived describes the dynamics of
quantum systems in the heisenberg
picture via the time evolution of the
observables
as a side note if we have an observable
like position or momentum which is time
independent in the schrolinger picture
then the derivative term on the right
hand side vanishes and we end up with
this simple differential equation for
the time evolution of observables in the
heisenberg picture
this also clearly shows that even when
observables are time independent in the
general picture they will in general be
time dependent in the heisenberg picture
the next idea i want to discuss is what
happens when we have a conservative
system
remember that this means that the
hamiltonian in the joiner picture does
not depend on time
also remember from earlier in the video
that for conservative systems the time
evolution operator u
is simply given by this exponential
function of the hamiltonian
let's also consider an observable a in
the joiner picture that is time
independent
and that commutes with the hamiltonian
remembering from the video on functions
operators that if two operators b and c
commute
then we have that b also commutes with
any function f of c
we can use this result to conclude that
this observable a
also commutes with the time evolution
operator as it is simply an exponential
function of the hamiltonian
putting everything together we can write
the observable a in the heisenberg
picture as given by this relation in
terms of the same observable in the
schrollinger picture
as a and u commute
we can rewrite this as u dagger
u
a
and as u is a unitary operator this
product here is equal to the identity
this means that we end up with the
observable a in the schroedinger picture
overall if we have a conservative system
and we also have a time independent
observable in the joiner picture that
commutes with the hamiltonian then we
can conclude that the observable in the
heisenberg picture here
is also time independent as it's simply
equal to the corresponding observable in
the joiner picture
in particular the conditions of this
setup apply when the observable a is the
hamiltonian of a conservative system as
the hamiltonian trivially commute with
itself what this means is that for a
conservative system
the hamiltonian in the heisenberg
picture
is equal to the hamiltonian in the
drawinger picture
and both are time independent
this is why for conservative systems
you'll often encounter the hamiltonian
written simply as the operator without
any sub
index why is this important
conservative systems are only a subset
of all possible systems but it turns out
that both schroedinger and heisenberg
pictures are most useful precisely for
conservative systems so these results
are actually extremely relevant
the study of non-conservative quantum
systems described by time dependent and
hamiltonians is of course also a very
important area but its mathematical
study usually requires the use of
another picture of time evolution in
quantum mechanics the so-called
interaction picture and more on that in
the videos linked in the description
so now that we have a good understanding
of the heisenberg picture the question
you're probably asking yourself is why
we would want to consider it in the
first place
after all it's completely equivalent to
the schrolinger picture so why bother
with it
in elementary quantum mechanics it's
typically easier to study time evolution
in quantum states rather than in
observables and this is why quantum
mechanics is initially taught in the
context of the schrollinger picture
however there are some areas in which
the heisenberg picture is more
convenient for example in the study of
the formal analogy between classical and
quantum mechanics
or in the study of some general
properties of time evolution in quantum
mechanics
let's see if i can convince you with a
quick example
let's derive the expression for the time
derivative of an expectation value of an
observable a
this is actually something we already
did in the video on aaron fest's theorem
using the schrollinger picture and you
may remember that the derivation in that
case is somewhat cumbersome
the answer that we found in that video
is that this expression is equal to the
expectation value of this commutator
plus the expectation value of this
derivative
now by contrast to the length derivation
in the rollinger picture deriving this
same result in the heisenberg picture is
actually pretty straightforward
to say this let's write the time
derivative of the expectation value of
observable a
explicitly it is given by this
expression where both states and
observables are in the heisenberg
picture as states are time independent
in the heisenberg picture we can move
the time derivative inside the bracket
here
to get this
this term here is simply the time
derivative of an observable in the
heisenberg picture and it's given by the
fundamental equation that describes time
evolution in the heisenberg picture that
we've derived earlier
using it we can directly write the time
derivative of the expectation value
as equal to the expectation value of the
commutator
plus the expectation value of the time
derivative
as the drawinger and heisenberg pictures
are related by unitary transformation
and unitary transformations conserve
expectation values then every term in
this expression at the top
is equal to every term in this
expression at the bottom
this way we confirm that we get the same
answer whether we do the derivation in
one picture or the other but doing this
in the heisenberg picture leads to much
simpler maths
to finish let's summarize what we found
by comparing the rollinger picture on
the one hand
and the heisenberg picture on the other
let's start with the states
in the stronger picture states are time
dependent
for the mod the state at time t is
obtained by the application of the time
evolution operator on the state at the
initial time t0
in the heisemberg picture states are
time independent
also we can obtain them from the
corresponding state in the joiner
picture by applying this unitary
transformation
which means that state in the heisenberg
picture are equal to states in the
schroedinger picture at the initial time
moving on to observables
in the joiner picture we have many
observables which are time independent
and these include position momentum or
angular momentum
we can also have observables with an
explicit time dependence
for example a hamiltonian with a time
dependent potential
in the heisenberg picture observables
are in general time dependent
and are related to the observables in
the joiner picture by this relation now
there is an exception to this rule which
is when we have a conservative system
and an observable that commutes with the
hamiltonian as in this case when we have
a time independent observable in the
joiner picture we also end up with the
time independent observable in the
heisenberg picture
overall comparing these two pictures we
can say that in the schroedinger picture
time evolution is governed by the states
whereas in the heisenberg picture it's
governed by the operators
in each picture we have an equation that
governs these dynamics
in the drawing our picture the joiner
equation is the key equation when
studying time evolution
while in the heisenberg picture we're
interested in the time evolution of
observables governed by this equation
the schroedinger and heisenberg pictures
provide two alternative but equivalent
ways to study time evolution in quantum
mechanics and in fact there are
infinitely many ways in which we could
apply a unitary transformation to obtain
an alternative description of time
evolution in quantum mechanics in this
context i encourage you to check out the
video on the interaction picture this is
a third picture of quantum mechanics
which is extremely useful when studying
systems with time-dependent potentials
and as always i hope you liked the video
and please subscribe